Let's go next to our caller from the seven
one seven area code.
Who's calling today from seven one seven?
Hi, my name's Omar.
Hey, Omar, what's going on?
I live in Pennsylvania and everything's opened
up.
And when I go to the gym, like most people
aren't wearing math and like all the coffee
shop, like they're kind of people just sitting
there working is really like worried about
the spread of the virus.
Now, I feel like concern.
Now, let me ask you this, Omar.
If the gym you've identified as a place that
looks dangerous, why are you going to the
gym?
That's a good question.
I really love the gym and it makes you feel
a lot better.
Yeah.
So I try to go there sparingly when they're
not a lot of people.
Right.
I don't know, like I I'd go maybe like twice
a week.
Normally I would be gone five times a week.
Right back and go in.
No, listen, I understood you are saying my,
um, my gym just e-mailed that they're opening
on Monday and workouts will be limited to
90 minutes, as if that's a problem for me,
right, Omar?
I mean, I'm not spending 90 minutes there,
but, you know, you're going you have to wipe
down every machine between use.
You're not allowed to hang out and talk to
people.
You have to have your temperature taken on.
You know, when I read the list to me, it's
like, oh, yeah, it's clearly way too dangerous.
It's warm right now.
I'll just workout outside or do YouTube workouts
or what.
That's the call I made.
But I'm totally with you.
I would love to be able to safely go to the
gym.
Yeah, it's just disheartening that, like,
no one's wearing my view.
I think it'd be a lot safer.
Everyone wore masks.
Absolutely not.
Absolutely.
So.
Well, listen, I guess all we can do is hope
that it improves.
I did go to a coffee shop last weekend.
And, you know, it's an outdoor seating only
sort of thing.
There were no tables with within 10 feet of
me.
I posted a picture of it on my Instagram.
It that felt safe.
And I think I'm just I'm going to only do
things that feels safe the way that they're
being done in my state.
And so I'll do outdoor dining.
I went and got my haircut, wore a mask the
entire time.
But I'm going to pass on the gym.
I'm in a pass on Indore for now.
All right, my friend, thank you so much for
the call.
Great to hear from you.